يعني منذ عده اسابيع لا يوجد معارك حاسمه
لا يوجد معارك حقيقيه
يوجد اشتباكات محدوده قد تكون اليد العليا
في جنوبوت للقوات الاوكرانيه اليد العليا
في شرق الايمان للقوات الروسيه لكن كلا
الجانبين لا يحقق انجازات حقيقيه على
الارض لهذا السبب تجد معظم التصريحات
والحديث يدور حول عمليات القصف والقصف
المضاد سواء بالطائرات المسيره او
بالصواريخ كما تم الحديث واشرت انت له عن
عمليه
عبور نهر الدنيا القوات الاوكرانيه تقول
نفذنا عمليه القوات الروسيه تقول افشلنا
العمليه هذا ماذا يعطي يعطي مؤشر على انها
عمليه محدوده صغيره جدا
توصف بعمليات الاغاره على اهداف محدده
وبالتالي قد تنجح في اداء مهمتها وقد يتم
احباطها وفي المشكله الحقيقيه ان الحقيقه
هي الضحيه لان البيانات متعارضه ولابد من
مرور ساعات او ايام حتى يتم الحديث
والتصريح بناء على تقارير حقيقيه من جهه
محايده لكن دعني اقول اصبحنا الان كان
طرفي القتال كانهم يخوضوا حرب استنزاف لان
كلا الجانبين لا يملك القدره على تطوير
ادائه الميداني خاصه الجانب الاوكراني
لماذا لان المناطق التي تعتبر منطلق
لعمليات مستقبليه ناجحه باتجاه القرم او
بحر اسوف او مولوتوبل او توك ماك تواجه
بعضية حقيقيه في اختراق الجدار الدفاعي
ثلاث ثلاثه انظمه او احزمه دفاعيه حتى هذه
اللحظه لا يزال القتال في الحزام الاول
كذلك الجانب الروسي يحاول ان يحقق انجازات
في منطقه ليمان لكن يبدو قدرات الميدانيه
لا تؤهل هذه القوات على تحقيق انجازات
كبيره فكاننا كان القتال بدا الدخول مرحله
حرب الاستنزاف الا اذا جد امر طارئ لاي من
الجانبين شكرا لك وفايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي